We're going to try something a little bit different in Computerphile today.
We're going to do a series of a few videos linking together, all about data analysis,
big data, data mining, this kind of stuff.
So I guess the idea is that maybe this is quite a broad topic.
We can't cover it in detail in one video and also some of the videos will link together.
So maybe if we have a little series on this we can start to really learn about
some of these in more detail, the idea being that by the time you've watched all the videos,
you'll have a really good idea of how to analyze data and what you can do with data because data isn't going away.
There's a lot of it about.
I spent a lot of time doing DIY and I'm always trying to buy new tools because it just seems like a good idea.
Right, so, you know, maybe I buy a certain kind of saw and then you know a few months later
they're starting to recommend me a slightly different kind of saw
that serves a slightly different purpose that suddenly I definitely need to be doing and I think 'ah yeah...
maybe I will buy that' and in the end I have 10 saws and I don't know how to use any of the saws